من جرائم ضد الانسانيه من استهداف
للمدنيين الامنين في بيوتهم والمستشفيات
والمراكز الصحيه والكوادر الصحيه ايضا
فاننا نشير الى ما يلي
اولا جرائم الاحتلال بحق شعبنا الفلسطيني
ما زالت
مستمره ولم تتوقف ولو للحظه واحده اما في
الشمال او في الجنوب ثانيا مازال الاحتلال
يستهدف الطواقم الصحيه بجميع
تشكيلاتها سواء بالقصف او الاعتقال حيث
استشهد العشرات منهم وما
يزال اكثر من 100 من الطواقم الطبيه داخل
المعتقلات
لا نعرف مصيرهم ولا باي ذنب اعتقلوا وعلى
راسهم دكتور محمد ابو سلميه مدير عام مجمع
الشفاء الطبي والدكتور احمد كحلوت مدير
مجمع كمال عدوان
بالشمال
ثالثا ما زالت منظومه الاسعاف
متوقفه بعد خروج اكثر من 70 سياره عن
الخدمه سواء بالقصف المباشر لها او
بتعطيلها او بتعطيل الطرق المؤديه الى
المستشفيات او بنقص السلوك اللازم لتشغيل
هذه الاسعافات حيث لم يتبقى الا ست سيرات
اسعاف تعمل توفر الوقود لها
رابعا هناك اضرار كبيره لحقت بالمستشفيات
والمراكز
الصحيه اما في المباني او في الاجهزه
الطبيه داخل هذه
المستشفيات خامسا في ظل شح الوقود وعدم
ادخاله من الجنوب الى الشمال فان الخدمات
الاساسيه في المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه
قد تعطلت وما زال تعطلها مستمر بسبب هذا
المنع لادخال
الوقود
سادسا نحن في وزاره الصحه في محافظه غزه
والشمال ما زلنا نكافح من اجل تشغيل بعض
الخدمات
الاساسيه وخاصه اقسام اليات والعنايه
المركزه وحضانات
الاطفال
سابعا ما زال مئات الالاف من النازحين
يفترشون الارض
ويلتحفون السماء في ظل هذا البرد القارس
وعدم توفر ادنى مقومات الحياه الاساسيه من
طعام وشراب ومع توقف خدمات الصرف الصحي
والنظافه واعمال البلديات بسبب نقص
السولار وهدم البنى التحتيه لهذه المؤسسات
فاننا نحذر من انتشار الاوبئه بين
النازحين وبين السكان حيث وخاصه بين
الاطفال
وكبار السن من الشيوخ
ثامنا هناك نقص كبير في الكوادر الصحيه
بعد ما اجبر الكثير منهم الى النزوح الى
جنوب قطاع غزه وبالتالي عدم القدره على
تشغيل كثير من الخدمات حتى ولو تم اصلاح
وتجهيز جميع الانظمه
التشغيليه وعلى ذلك نطالب مؤسسات المجتمع
الدولي والمؤسسه الامميه ومؤسسات حقوق
الانسان وكل صاحب ضمير حي في هذه العالم
بما يلي
اولا السعي الحثيث لدى الاحتلال للافراج
عن كوادرنا
الصحيه
ثانيا ضروره الضغط للسماح بعوده كوادرنا
الصحيه من الجنوب الى الشمال والتي اجبرت
على
النزوح للمساعده في بناء المنظومه الصحيه
داخل مستشفياتنا ومرا زنا الصحيه في غزه
والشمال ثالثا ضروره ادخال السولار اللازم
لتشغيل الانظمه المختلفه في المستشفيات
مثل محطات الاكسجين ومضخات المياه ومحطات
التحليه
رابعا المساعده في اصلاح ما تم تخريبه من
مبان واجهزه طبيه داخل هذه
المؤسسات خامسا ادخال الاجهزه والمعدات
والادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه لتسهيل اعمال
هذه المنظومه
الصحيه
سادسا السماح بادخال الاطقم الطبيه
المختلفه من خارج قطاع غزه للمساعده في
التخفيف من معاناه شعبنا وخاصه الجرحى
والمرضى منهم سابعا واخيرا ضروره السماح
للجرحى والمرضى للسفر الى الخارج لاستكمال
علاجهم حيث نحن نعاني من نقص شديد من
كوادر وانظمه تشغيل وايضا من مستلزمات
طبيه تساعد في تخفيف هذه المعاناه والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه